vingt mille dollars c'est ce que je vous
donnais ce foutu et ma femme
tenez on dirait que vous allez tourner
de l'oeil je vous ai observés çà c'est
le destin pour un vendredi est passé en
catégorie 3 et s'attaque à la côte du
golfe
vous mettre à l'aise toutes les preuves
désigne comme coupable
dites moi ce qui s'est passé je suis
innocent
je jure alors c'est vrai votre femme ne
vous traite pas comme elle devrait
même si l'on freine en conquête on fout
je
je sais que vous pouvez le faire
la vie sans une touche d'amour rien du
tout
elle est dangereuse
m
valor massart confiance c'est à cause du
train et vous pensez pas commis ce
meurtre
alors t'as qu'à aller visiter à cal
de quoi tu parles
tu vas adorer
[Musique]
tha